ｼﾞｬﾝ!
ﾋﾟｨｭﾝ!
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです。
物をなくすという行為、皆さんしたことありますでしょうか
あのー自慢じゃないんですけど
僕ほど物をなくす人はそうそういないと思います
そのー小学校のころからはじまってたんですけど
学校からいえにかえる時
に気づいたんですけども
宿題とかも基本忘れるし
とりあえず
バカなんですよ。
でもーこの歳になっても忘れ物ひどすぎて
財布もなくすし、家の鍵もなくすし、
ホンットに物なくしがひどすぎる
あの、多分皆さんが想像している
何倍も僕は物をなくしてます
そんな僕がもう
いろんな鍵を持っているわけですよ
全部の鍵を一つにしているんですけども
これすらもなくす！
ﾀﾞﾝｯ!!
このままじゃまずい。
じゃあ、どうすれば鍵をなくさないで済むかって
考えた時に
キーホルダーってものを皆さんつけると思うんですよ
鍵に何かこう、ストラップとか
物をつけると目立つし、大きくなるから
結構なくす確率は
かなり減ると思うんですけども
このサイズでも１日１，２回は無くすんで
なんとかせねば。
なんとかせねばって思ったので
今回キーケースをもっとでかくしようと思います
どうでかくしようかというと
やっぱりキーホルダーをつけるしかないと思うんですけど、
もうなるべく大きければ大きいほど
僕はたぶん鍵をなくす確率が減ると思うので
今回はキーホルダーをなるべく買おうと思います
何個買えばいいのか僕ちょっとわか↑んないんですよ
たぶん大きければ大きいほどいいと思うんで
その大きさは…
というわけで今からTwitterにつぶやきます
まあ要するにコレRTされればされるほど
僕が鍵をなくす確率が減るので
むしろプラスなんですよ
ｱﾘｶﾞﾀｲｱﾘｶﾞﾀｲ
皆さんのご協力で僕の物なくしが軽減されるという
もうwin-winの関係ですよっ
ではつぶやきます　ﾊｲｯ!
ﾋｭｴｰﾝ(不穏な音)
ﾔﾍﾞ　やったやった
(そのまま「やった」と言いつつ立ち去る
やったやった
あー　現時点で今373円分ですね
あー　ヤバい
985円になってしまった
あー　1000円超えました1000円超えました
時間が大体…
今日の夕方までにします
あー今　2000円ですね
まだ2600円　2600RTなら2600円なんで
多分まあ、５，６個かな。
まあまあ失くさねえぜくらい
ﾔﾍﾞ　3000円ですね
3000円だとまあそこそこ多いなくらい
まだまだです。
（今、彼がのうのうとカレーパンを食べている間でさえ）
（RT数は、伸び続けているのであった。）
5時まであと3分前でございます
5時ぴったりでRTを締め切って
その値段分買いますので
もうしばしお待ちください
Zzz...
\ｷﾀｯ/
ﾜｧ　びっくりした
もう5時？　ヤバいヤバい
ハイ！ハイ！
というわけで今のRT数の分買います
えー　こちら！
なんということでしょう。
かつて、あんなに小さかったキーケースは
ここまで変化しました。(ﾆｯｺﾘ)
あっ、お疲れ～
(ｼﾞｬﾗｼﾞｬﾗ)
えーRT数が
5万千7百４じゅう…
あーっ！！　増えちゃった！！
ｹﾞﾎｯ　ｹﾞﾎｯ
51750！
もうこれで決定ですね…